[Music] A
long time ago, the island suddenly appeared above the sea The island named
Waffle was surrounded by stormy barriers
that blocked all who approached
One day, I met a certain pirate, and
he turned to Waffle.  The pirate, who said he had landed on the
island
before, told me that he had seen a mysterious girl and a terrifying giant on the island, but
he was taken away by the navy that followed him.
There were a lot of people aiming for that, but in the
end
none of them came back
.
A legendary island where the road leads to heaven
Japanese style and
my name is
Lim
Something came out of my body
You see,
pirates
are full of nasty guys who use violence against the weak
But they might be something different from the pirates
you've seen so far Come back, he won't stop attacking until he kills you all Once he
finds the cube, his
strength will return
[MUSIC]
I'll find more and more and regain my strength It
can't be helped I'll
lend you a little help from now on I'll take you to a certain place
[MUSIC]
Yes, this is
the world of your memories
[MUSIC]